hello everyone and welcome to today's
live broadcast addressing the challenges
of bio conjugation for improved
cross-linking and modifications
presented by Gregg Hermanson chief
technology officer and principal at
Arora micro wave solutions incorporated
and the president of Gregg T Hermanson
in corporate I am Xavier Gutierrez of
lab routes and I will be your moderator
for today's event we are delighted to
bring you this educational web seminar
presented by at lab roots and sponsored
by thermo Fisher Scientific for more
information about a sponsor visit
www.hp.com/recycle that ask a question
box located on the far left of your
screen and type your questions into the
drop-down box that appears on the screen
well answer as many questions as we have
time for at the end of the presentation
if you have trouble seeing or hearing
your presentation please use the ask a
question box to let us know that you're
having a problem this presentation is
educational and thus offers continuing
education credits please click on the
continuing education credits tab located
in the top right corner of the
presentation window and follow the
process to obtain your credits now if
you would please join me in welcoming
mr. Hermanson I will now turn the
presentation over to him Thank You
Xavier
and let's go to the second slide and
we'll see where we're going today in
this seminar we've got a lot lot of
ground to cover so we're moving right in
the outline for today's seminar is we're
going to look at functional groups on
biomolecules proteins elico nucleotides
and carbohydrates single can't glycans
and then we're going to look at some of
the principle reactions that are done in
bio conjugation on those biomolecules
namely amine reactions Thile reactions
and carbonyl reactions and during the
course of the seminar some of the
important
knowledge that can be gained will
include what reactive groups are
available and the reactions used for
them in bio conjugation the major
products of each reaction the hydrolysis
and side reactions that each one might
have interfering substances that you
might want to avoid how to optimize the
reactions and tips and tricks along the
way
so let's jump right into functional
groups on biomolecules functional
targets on biomolecules are really
highly diverse on proteins and peptides
they all contain an abundance of targets
for conjugation and in mobilization do
the variety of amino acid side chains
that are present and some of the
principal ones that are often targeted
are amines aisles carbohydrates
carboxylates and glycans the folding one
thing to keep in mind is that the
folding of the polypeptide chain may
prevent some reactions from occurring
with residues having low accessibility
so not every protein has every residue
available an antibody for instance may
have dozens and dozens of amines but
maybe 15 to 20 of those amines are
readily accessible and highly reactive
can also target groups on carbohydrates
and glycol conjugates depending upon the
type of carbohydrate it might contain a
reducing end for example an aldehyde or
within its structure it may have it
adjacent hydroxyl groups or dials that
can be oxidized to aldehydes or amines
that can be directly targeted or even
carboxylate so it can be coupled to and
glycolic hands are present on
glycoproteins and glycolipids and we'll
look at their structures in some detail
in a few slides on DNA and RNA and
nucleotides reactions can be targeted at
the five prime phosphate group the
ribose dial has a three prime and on RNA
and certain positions on the bases
nucleophiles nucleic acids however are
often less reactive than nucleophiles on
proteins so there's some specialized
reactions that have been developed for
our the nucleotides that we'll look at
in a moment
so if you looked at reactivity in
proteins this is an example peptide that
just happens to contain just about every
functional group that can be targeted or
modified in a protein molecule and if
you look from the left side towards the
right on the left hand side we have the
amine terminus and we can target a means
on the Alpha amine or on the lysine
Epsilon amine side chain the third amino
acid over can also target the
carboxylates on aspartic acid and
glutamic acid a very popular target our
Styles on cysteine residues the residue
right in the middle others that can be
modified however include the guanidinium
group on the side chain of arginine the
phenolic ring on the sidechain of
tyrosine and even tryptophan can be
modified with some specialized reagents
methionine is also reactive but it's
rarely targeted specifically because
some of the products of those reactions
are actually reversible and labile so in
targeting methionine you also target
cysteine but the Messiah named any
reactions with methionine will break
back down and finally you have the
middle vole ring on a side chain of
histidine which can be iota nated or
reacted with alkyl halides around the
outer perimeter in red of this group of
peptides are the principal reactions
that can be used with each of these
functional groups
with all ego nucleotides it's a bit
different whether it's RNA or DNA you
can target the five prime phosphate
group with its present and that's
usually targeted much the same way as a
carboxylic acid can be activated with
the water-soluble carbon I M at EDC and
with oligonucleotides you do that in the
presence of a middle and that forms an
activated phosphoryl emitters aligned
which can be then reacted with amines
hyde resides or amino Lac C groups to
target and couple to specifically only
one end of an algal nucleotide with RNA
also the three prime end can be targeted
through praia date oxidation of the dial
on the ribose at the three prime end and
after oxidation to formaldehydes
they can be coupled with amines hyde
resides or amino outside maxie groups as
well the base groups if you notice that
guanine cytosine and adenine all contain
what appear to be amines however the
amines are rarely reactive because
they're actually in resonance with the
ring structure which dramatically
decreases the reactivity of these nh-2
groups but ring structures the carbon
atoms on some of the rings like wanting
and cytosine in particular guanine can
be brominated with n-bromosuccinimide
and coupled to amines through the
bromination point and with cytosine
bisulfite can be used to activate one of
the positions on the unsaturated
carbon-carbon bond and that leads to the
ability to do a transamination reaction
at the nh-2 group with substitution of a
spacer arm that can be then coupled to
using other reagents so the reactions
with all ago nucleotides are a bit
different than proteins but the
chemistry that's been developed has been
well developed and works very well
with functional groups and glycans and
carbohydrates these are often modifiers
of protein molecules or lipid molecules
and they have complex structures but
within the structures there's certain
points that can be pariah date oxidized
either dials on for instance beta D
galactose or on the dials on terminal
silac acid residues in dilute solutions
of pariah date the dials on sialic acid
can be targeted specifically at close to
zero degrees C and will leave untouched
the beta D galactose residues and higher
concentrations of variety and room
temperature you can oxidize also any
beta d GL residues so once forming the
aldehydes on the glycan you can couple
with amine side resides or amino XE
groups also
so let's look at the major reactions
done with these functional groups first
of all the dozens and dozens of
reactions that have been developed for
bio conjugation there's probably about a
dozen I'm listed 10 here that are
commonly used and repeatedly used and
available on many of the reagents that
are sold commercially that's reactive
esters which include NHS esters TFP
esters or NHS carbonates which react
with amines to form a mid bonds you can
also activate a carboxylic acid using a
car bowtie image like EDC and reacted in
the presence of NHS or soulful NHS to
form an NHS ester soulful NHS ester and
that activation product can then go on
to react with amines to form a mid bonds
and we'll look at this reaction in great
detail in a few slides
malee amide groups are very popular to
use they're available on many
cross-linking reagents or modification
reagents and they react with cysteine
dials to form thioether bonds aldehydes
can be produced as we saw with glycans
and carbohydrates they form shift bases
with amines and if they're reduced with
reductive alkylation they form secondary
or tertiary amine bonds or they can
react with hydrazine groups to find form
hydrogen bonds or form oxime bonds with
amino AXI groups so is a variety of
options without leads private oxidation
is often used as an intermediate step in
the reactions of bio conjugation to
formaldehyde from dials used to create
reactive sites especially on
carbohydrates and glycans and disulfide
Reduction is often used this is the
formation of files for conjugation
through from disulfides within proteins
and this uses DT T or T sup or other
thio reducing agents E
proxy groups react with amines sales or
hydroxyls and form secondary amine
thioether or ether bonds any poxes are
often used to immobilize ligand onto
particles and chromatography supports
hello sotl groups like iOS a teal or
bromo NASA teal reacts with tiles
rapidly to form thioether bonds and also
photo reactive groups can be used for
nonspecific targeting when studying
protein-protein interactions for example
and there's a variety of photo reactive
groups available and cycloaddition
reactions have gained popularity
especially the click chemistry action
with copper or copper free methods to
form a cyclo addition product
but looking at even these most popular
reactions there's three sets of
reactions that occur most often and
let's look at amine reactions with amine
reactions the most popular reactive
group in existence right now is the N
hydrolysis in amide or NHS ester it is
certainly essential technology for amine
conjugation and it's used in many dozens
and dozens of reagents available to
either cross-linked molecules or modify
them an NHS ester is the most common
reactive group used in bio conjugation
and they are spontaneously reactive with
amines and almost always work well
there's two principal types of NHS
esters and standard in HS ester or a
soulful NHS ester and if you look at the
compounds below on the left hand side it
shows two compounds that use NHS esters
if you look on the left hand side of
those compounds you'll see the NHS ring
structure which is esterified to a
carboxylic acid and on the right hand
side the two to two structures show the
same compounds only with soulful NHS
groups and the presence of the soulful
adds a negative charge character to the
entire compound which is strong enough
to water-soluble eyes the compound prior
to conjugation
so NHS ester reactions with amines
involve a isolation reaction with you
mean where the amine group unshared pair
of electrons being highly negatively
charged interacts and is attracted to
the carbonyl carbon atom which is on the
NHS ester because that's partially
positively charged this interaction
causes collisions and it eventually
kicks off the leaving group NH s to form
an amide bond and the amide bond is
highly stable and that's why n adjusters
are popular this reaction proceeds
rapidly and the product of the reaction
the amide bond forms very quickly and is
stable
the resultant bond is stable and the
reaction occurs slightly at alkaline pH
in aqueous buffers or an organic
solution can be done with a base present
like the map or te a the optimal pH
conditions are dependent however on the
type of NHS ester compound being used
and the rate of hydrolysis that may
occur at any given pH typically we say
that NHS esters are soulful NHS esters
work best between pH seven and nine but
it's really important to optimize for
each different compound that's being
used some of them will work best around
pH seven or 7.5 others may work best at
pH eight point five four eight point
seven it just depends upon the type of
compound that the NHS ester is present
upon
now reactions with NHS esters with amino
acids and proteins occur with the amines
principally which is the n-terminal
amine alpha amine and lysine epsilon
amino groups to form the amide bond and
that's the major target so if you're
reacting an NHS ester containing cross
linker with a protein molecule you're
anticipating that that is going to
result in an amide bond mainly with
lysine side chains and with it alpha
amino groups however it can also react
with histidine through it's a metal
nitrogen side chain to form a carbonyl
am it is a light now unfortunately this
reactive product this product is
unstable and in itself reactive it's a
reactive intermediate that unfortunately
reacts very quickly with water and
hydrolyzes so if there is a lot of
histidine present in a protein you may
actually need to optimize the amount of
NHS ester containing reagent up a little
bit in concentration to overcome the
accelerated hydrolysis that histidine
might cause in the this type of reaction
NH s esters also can react with serine
or threonine hydroxyls to form esters
but it's often difficult to get this
reaction to specifically occur in
aqueous solution the same with tyrosine
h groups and cysteine sulfide row groups
these are side reactions that sometimes
occur fortunately cysteine doesn't often
occur in free form in most proteins so
when an NHS ester is reacted with a
protein sustains are not the principal
target and with serine and threonine
hydroxyls or tyrosine hydroxyl
because this is an interesting side
reaction that's been understood only
recently so NHS esters normally have
difficulty modifying searing hydroxyls
in aqueous solution because of the
competing effect of a much higher
concentration of water but when serine
Oh H groups haven't be held in practice
two amino acid side chains having a
transient modification potential then
the hydroxyls can be modified an example
of this is either in a single peptide or
in a series of polypeptide chains where
a histidine side chain a middle group is
held in proximity to a serine hydroxyl
group the NHS ester actually can react
with the histidine imidazole group to
form this unstable carbonyl middles ol
I'd seen in the middle and because the O
H group is closed by an N oh ship facial
shift can occur and transfer the NHS
ester containing compound over to the
hydroxyl on searing this can be seen
with certain proteins and certain
peptides and has been studied by madly
at all in 2009 now the same thing
type of reaction can also occur with
tyrosine and threonine hydroxyls where
if the histidine occurs in proximity to
either a tyrosine O age group or a three
and a no H group the same type of
reaction can occur with initial complex
ation with the histidine nitrogen and
then an N o a CO shift over to the
corresponding O age group the relative
reactivity of this potential reaction is
serine occurs more commonly than
tyrosine and tyrosine more commonly than
three inning
but it does occur so if you're modifying
peptides and you happen to have
histidine groups near serine/threonine
or tyrosine residues and by mass spec or
other means you find that some of those
o H groups have been modified this is
indeed probably the side reaction that
has occurred NHS esters also have a
competing hydrolysis reaction which was
unavoidable in aqueous solution in
general hydrolysis occurs as the rate R
as the pH becomes more alkaline
hydrolysis occurs with increasing rate
alkalinity probably increases the
nucleophilicity of the unshared pairs of
electrons on the oxygen water because
there are fewer protons available to
associate with them so NHS esters
typically are most stable at pH values
between 3 & 6 so if you are working with
an NHS ester and need to purify an
intermediate in aqueous solution having
it on the acid side will give you a
little bit more time to purify it with
limited hydrolysis in a long in a paper
published at the beginning of affinity
chromatography and the reactions to
immobilize affinity ligands on the
chromatography supports quadric resides
and preak studied NHS esters and their
coupling of amine containing ligands to
agarose and they looked at the rate of
hydrolysis at pH six point three and
eight point six and as you can see here
at pH six point three the rate of
hydrolysis is considerably less than the
rate of hydrolysis at pH eight point six
so if you're reacting a molecule at
elevated pH up around eight point five
to nine you may have unacceptably rapid
hydrolysis which will compete with the
actual coupling reaction
similarly with soulful NHS esters in 91
grown back and V studies soulful and H
SLC biotin to see what their relative
rate of stability of the soulful NHS
group on the compound would be to
changes in pH as you can see around pH 3
or 4 the half-life of hydrolysis is
hundreds of minutes in length but as you
climb up to the areas where the reaction
would actually be done the half-life at
pH less a 7.2 is less than 50 minutes at
pH 8 that drops to around 10 minutes at
over pH 9 you're down to just a few
minutes of half-life V as the rate of
hydrolysis quickly accelerates now an
alternative TFP a ester to NHS ester is
the TFP ester
that's tetra fluoro phenol esters they
react also with amines the four Mamet
bond similar to NHS esters TFP esters
however been found to provide better
hydrolytic stability in higher yields of
a manned bond formation than NHS esters
especially at alkaline pH so some
reagents are available now with TFP
esters on them and NHS esters and you
may want to try both types of reagents
if you're optimizing a bio conjugation
procedure because TFP esters not only
are they more stable to hydrolysis but
they have better yields of amide bond
formation in the two graphs at the at
the bottom and the one on the left
studies the reaction to hydrolysis at pH
7 of a TSP ester compared to an NHS
ester you can see after 240 minutes
about 20% of the TFP ester was
hydrolyzed whereas at the same time
frame 50 percent of the NHS ester was
hydrolyzed
so you get better hydrolytic stability
of TFP ester and better amine coupling
capability and even at pH 10 which is
extraordinarily high alkaline for
hydrolysis of NHS esters the NHS ester
was essentially completely hydrolyzed
after about 150 to 200 minutes whereas
TFP esters still had 60% of their
activity left
even after 240 minutes
some of the interfering substances to be
aware of for NHS ester congregations are
listed here primarily nitrogenous
buffers containing primary or secondary
amines for example trysts or metas all
beware of amino acids and their
derivatives such as alpha amino groups
onglyza Zorich and hist which are often
added to buffers also glutathione
contains a primary amine so if you've
got a cell like extract and you haven't
gotten rid of small molecules
glutathione is present in high
concentrations and may be a primary
interfering agent with NHS or TFP esters
secondary and primary amine containing
polymers for instance polyethylene amine
will react with NHS esters also amino
sugars glucose amine or hydro Zaid
hydrazine amino AXI compounds ammonium
salts too now ammonium bicarbonate
ammonium citrate ammonium acetate
ammonium sulfate etc are often additives
to buffers to stabilize or extract
proteins from cells or tissues if the
ammonium ion isn't removed and it's
present in high enough concentration it
may compete in the reaction now
fortunately ammonium is almost always
protonated in aqueous solution but there
is an equilibrium and nh3 will also be
all always be present to a certain
degree and it's nh3 is going to react
with either TFP or NHS ester so it's
better to remove ammonium compounds
before doing the reaction is i too often
add as a as a preservative in buffer
solutions reacts to form a CoA sighs
it's a moderate nucleophile and it will
interfere some people have done
successfully conjugations in the
presence of 0.2 o 2 percent sodium azide
but I would recommend typically avoiding
azide and removing it prior to a
conjugation reaction be careful of old
urea it may break down to carbamic acid
which one can decomposes into co2 and
ammonia the ammonia being the
interfering substance
also Thile containing reducing agents
ttt2 mercaptoethanol tumor capitalism
and other Thyle containing compounds the
file will react with an ester an
activated ester and beware of other
proteins are blocking agents added to a
solution which may may contain a means
such as BSA they're often added to
antibodies so if you purchase an
antibody and you want to conjugate or
modify it make sure it doesn't have a
carrier BSA or something else
it contains an amine
another way to form a reactive aster is
the use of water-soluble carbon diamonds
and carbon diamonds like EDC or edik can
be used to form reactive esters from
carboxylates directly in aqueous
solution EDC is called a zero length
cross linker which means it forms an
amide bond between a carboxylate
containing molecule and amine containing
molecule with no intervening linker arm
as frequently used a couple antibodies
or other amine containing molecules to
carboxylated particles especially
magnetic particles and this is the
typical reaction that you'll see that
EDC can react with a carboxylate to form
an intermediate Oh a CLI so various
derivatives so the intermediate ester is
the component that we actually reacts
with you mean to form the final product
the amide bond
however this typical reaction sequence
isn't driving really what goes on and
EDC does have some potential
deficiencies I don't want to go into
great detail in this slide but if you
look at EDC the top compound in the
center in order for it to be reactive
with carboxylic acids it needs to be
first protonated that intermediate
protonated form can hydrolyze at that
point and hydrolyze to an ISO area which
is then inactivated it can go on to
react with a carboxylic acid to form the
Oso ISO virya derivative and that
derivative needs to be protonated again
to form an intermediate reactive carbo
cation and that reactive carbo cation
can also hydrolyze back to the
carboxylic acid and the ice over urea
product essentially in it in activating
it at that step if it goes on to react
with you mean it gives the desired
product the amide bond formation which
is over on the right hand side but even
that reactive carbo cation can then
cycle eyes to form an
hydride or if II D C is used in too much
too high of an excess you can have an H
azo shift to form an ACO iso urea
derivative which is then inactive so you
can see that EDC reactions are not quite
as simple as the previous slide and many
of the reaction sequences in the
literature describes there's a lot of
places where EDC can have side reactions
towards hydrolysis or competing
reactions that the detered diminish the
amide bond formation there's a paper in
the mid-90s that studied EDC in each of
the reaction steps that I showed in the
previous slide first with regards to
hydrolytic stability of EDC versus pH
they found that EDC is quite stable from
about ph 6.5 on up above ph 9 almost pH
10 you can see all of those points
indicate that the activity remaining
even after 300 minutes is nearly a
hundred percent at higher pH values even
slightly on the acidic side it was still
very stable however dropping down to
acidic values at three point nine five
or two point five - it was rapid
hydrolysis of EDC at those two pH values
so keep this in mind because they also
studied the rate of reaction of EDC with
carboxylates versus pH and in this case
it was found that the best PHS for
activating carboxylic acids we're on the
acid side from about 3.5 to about 4.5
with activity also being possible at
higher pH values so at the PHS where EDC
hydrolyzes the fastest it's also the
most effective at reacting with
carboxylic acids and forming the
intermediate ester
now what about a mid bond formation
using EDC well it turns out that a mid
bond formation if it's done in a
one-step reaction where everything's in
solution simultaneously if you look at
the graph on the right hand side
ethylene diamine and in the yellow dot
dots was present in this in the solution
with the carboxylate containing compound
and the EDC simultaneously and these
represent the yields of a mid bond
formation in a one-step procedure if a
two-step reaction was done where the
carboxylic acid was reacted first
activated excess EDC was removed and
then ethylene diamine was added it
decreased the yield somewhat but even at
higher PHS it remained stable in terms
of the yield of a matte bond formation
with benzoyl I mean being an aromatic
aryl amine you would expect the
reactivity of an arrow mean to be
somewhat less and their yields of Hammad
bond formation in this experiment were
indeed less than ethylene diamine and a
two-step in reality using EDC reactions
in this type of procedure whether one
step or two step a pH of about six
provides very good compromise between
the rate of hydrolysis of EDC EDC is
quite stable at pH six an aqueous
solution and the yield of a mat bond
formation is at a maximum or nearly a
maximum at pH six however you still get
the potential of all those side
reactions that EDC could have so how do
you make et Cie reactions more efficient
it's possible actually to limit EDC side
reactions through an initial reaction
with NHS or soulful NHS so in this case
we're creating an intermediate NHS or
soulful NHS ester that will provide
better stability towards hydrolysis and
won't suffer from any of the EDC
rearrangement reactions so this reaction
occurs if you have
just showing a particle with carboxylase
grouped on reacting with EDC to form the
intermediate Osei surya reactive ester
and then with soulful NHSN solution in
excess this reacts with the EDC ester to
form the soulful NHS ester intermediate
which then goes on to react with the
amino compound and form the amide bond
star OHS in 1986 published a paper which
demonstrated that in the presence of
soulful NHS the EDC reaction was
dramatically improved and the yields
could be very high compared with the
same reaction done without soulful NHS
present
so let's move now to thio reactions
particularly Meili amide reactions with
files Valley might reactions are
actually a second most popular bio
conjugation reaction done behind only R
activists or coupling to amines which we
just looked at files are also the second
most popular targeted functional group
behind amines so that's why you find
thousands of literature references that
site to use some elamite reactions and
creating bio conjugates and dozens of
commercial avail available bio conjugate
reagents which have one or more melamed
groups they are often reactive second in
hetero by functional cross-linking
procedures because they usually are more
stable than the reactive esters in
aqueous solution so in a cross linker
containing a reactive ester plus some
MLM ID the reactive ester would be
reacted with an amine let's say on a
protein first and then secondary
reaction would occur which is shown at
the bottom here where the Mallee amide
ring with the double bond would be
reacted with a file containing compound
or peptide and Athiya would couple to by
addition to the double bond to form the
thioether product however this reaction
doesn't really tell the full story this
is a typical reaction you see in the
literature but what really can occur is
shown on the next slide this is some of
the true reactions that occur with Mally
amide groups they're more complex than
most schemes would lead one to believe
the desired product is accompanied by
hydrolysis products and a number of
different derivatives including the
potential to create different stereo
chemical species so if you look at this
reaction scheme the maleimide
on the upper left initially it can react
with the file and form the thioether
product as we saw on the previous slide
the Mallee amide ring also can hydrolyze
in the presence of water to open up the
ring structure to a Mallee amick acid
derivative which is shown just below the
Mallee amide now the ring open
can occur on either side of the ring and
form two different stereochemical
products unfortunately both of these
hydrolysis products are a relatively
unreactive with aisles so the hydrolysis
of malya might essentially inactivates
the double bond to the additional files
however if you do successfully link a
file containing molecule and form the
thioether derivatives shown on the upper
right notice that there's two
derivatives that are possible and even
though they look similar there are
actually two different stereochemical
forms and so if you if you're working
with a research conjugate it doesn't
really matter because you're probably
forming a conjugate that's going to be
used in a detection procedure and it
won't be used in vivo however if you're
working with therapeutics forming
antibody drug conjugates or something
else
these stereochemical products can make a
difference in activity in vivo
now once the thioether product is formed
the ring structure of the Mallee amic
acid that's left can also hydrolyze and
I'm showing two of those hydrolysis
products but if you recognize that I'm
only showing the ring opening on one
side of each of these there's two other
products also that conform so from one
successful file reaction with a Mallee
amide you can get two different
thioether derivatives and four different
hydrolysis products so there is a
potential that you could have six
different products in solution
simultaneously
Meli might reaction rate also was
studied with selfless mcc modified
proteins so BSA was activated with
soulful SMCC which contains an NHS ester
on one side soulful NHS ester and a
Mallee amide on the other end and BSA
then gets modified with soulful SMCC
through an amide bond and the excess
Meili amide on the other end of the
cross linker sticks off of BSA can be
used to create immunogen's from file
containing peptides or other molecules
so cysteine was coupled in this
experiment to Mele my BSA for the
indicated times in the graph and then
the amount of cysteine left in solution
was immediately determined using the
elements assay the difference between
the amount of cysteine initially in the
reaction and the amount remaining in
solution at any given time equals the
amount coupled to the melee by groups so
what you can see from the graph is that
the Melamed reaction is essentially
complete within two hours and usually a
lot faster than that and this is at pH 7
point 2 and if you're working with
proteins that are activated with
sulfides I'm CeCe I would let them go to
2 hours because you're going to approach
100% coupling yield at that time frame
now in earlier early paper by Gregory
the box over on the right hand side in
1955 studied the stability of an ethyl
melia might as reaction with sulfide row
groups in solution and what they found
was with a variety of sulfhydryl groups
and Sol you might could couple with them
in solution small molecules within only
a couple minutes getting nearly a
hundred percent yield
so the slower reaction with proteins is
simply due to the fact that the protein
and the Meili amide modification on the
protein is present in much lower
concentrations then what Gregory
analyzed back in 1955 but still the
malli might fail reaction is very rapid
so even with the
number of side reactions and different
products that can form with this
reactive group it is still used in
research to a large extent and
diagnostics the only time you want to be
careful with it is what will happen when
you're making a therapeutic compound by
this linkage reaction now malya malya
might hydrolysis also has been studied
the stability of a Mallee amide group is
dependent not only on the pH but also
upon the neighboring chemical groups the
more alkaline the greater the hydrolysis
rate will be but different cross linkers
can provide dramatically different
stabilities in aqueous solution and what
has been found is cross linkers like
SMCC and soulful SMCC have relatively
high stability at pH 7.2 due to their
cyclohexane ring next to the Mele my
group where as soulful and MBs and
soulful SMPP are much more labile to
hydrolysis as the graph shows however if
you've modified a protein with one of
these mullet belen might cross linkers
and you want to purify that modified
protein away from EXO's cross linker
they can be purified by size-exclusion
chromatography
rapidly at pH 6 with little to no loss
of Meili might activity because at ph 6
the Mallee amide ring only hydrolyzes
very very slowly
now there's a couple of caveats to keep
in mind number one is the reversibility
of Meili amides IOI's or bonds and this
has been found recently in a number of
publications the presence of high
concentrations of thiols in solution has
been shown to potentially reverse the
thioether bond and this is done by
undergoing exchange with the second file
through a retro michael reaction process
where the thioether on the left-hand
side of this reaction scheme slowly can
lose that file and reform the melia my
double bond in the presence of another
file and solution that second tile
if it's present in higher concentration
then then can substitute for the first
style on the malya malya might ring thus
kicking off the first conjugate and
replacing it with a second also a nearby
amine group held in close proximity to
the Mallee might bio ether such as
lysine epsilon amino group has been
shown to cause an SM shift which can
effectively cleave the initial thioether
bond and form a secondary amine bond so
the thioether in the bottom reaction
sequence is neighboring or right close
to a lysine side chain amine if thats io
ether bond should run through a retro
micro process come off reform that
double bond the file won't be able to
find and react again with that double
bond before the amine gets to it and you
can actually cleave off part of the
conjugate this reaction sequence
actually was found to occur in a Mallee
amide conjugated antibody drug conjugate
because l boomin actually held the drug
in its cleff human albumin in vivo and
in the cleft of albumin was a sidechain
lysine that was held in proximity to the
male you might thioether linkage and
this is exactly what happened in aqueous
solution or in insu
what are some of those interfering
substances for melamed conjugations the
obvious style containing disulfide
reducing agents avoid them cysteine Dial
glutathione - it's typically at 5 milli
molar at least in animal cells also
avoid t sep and other strong reducing
agents like sodium borohydride gets at
all in 1999 observed that when labeling
with melia made both t sep and d TT
substantially decreased labeling
efficiently compared to no reductant
being present also be aware that
alkaline pH increases hydrolysis and
also promotes side reactions with amines
recently it's been found that group 6
axial metal aids such as molybdate and
chromate both will quickly hydrolyze
melamed rings and open them also metal
salts and samples will rapidly oxidize
styles to disulfides
or facilitate that oxidation for example
metal salts and blood extracts and
purified blood proteins which typically
have high iron content in this case add
EDTA or eg ta to inhibit oxidation of
files and finally BSA albumins typically
contain a single free-style group which
will react with mel you might so be
aware if you're doing a conjugation and
you add BSA as a stabilizer to the file
conjugation reaction it may in fact
conjugate with BSA instead of your
intended target now finally let's look
at carbon eel reactions particularly
those with aldehydes and ketones so l
died and ketone reactions and bio
conjugation are probably the third most
popular conjugate reaction that's done
amines being number one files being
number two and reactions with aldehydes
and ketones number three now with amine
groups aldehydes and ketones can form
shift bases and are unstable and easily
hydrolyzed in order to stabilize them
the first reaction shows that the shift
base can be read
used with Sonam cyano borohydride to
form a secondary amine linkage which is
stable the second reaction shows the
reaction between an aldehyde and a hydro
side group the hydro-zone bond is much
more stable than a shift based linkage
with an amine and a aldehyde but I would
still recommend reducing with cyano
borohydride because it forms a much more
stable substituted hydro side the final
reaction and amino actually group with
an aldehyde forms an oxime linkage and
this is much more stable to hydrolysis
and doesn't typically need to be reduced
afterwards so proteins and amino
molecules can be modified to create
aldehydes and in this case using a
reagent that has a tsps or on one side a
peg 12th spacer and then a formul
benzoate molecule on the other so it has
an arrow aldehyde group on one end and
an ester reactive ester on the other end
it can be reactive as a protein molecule
and mean containing molecule and form an
amide bond and the other end of the
structure will create aldehydes on the
protein surface for further conjugation
also aldehydes can be formed from dials
and glycans and other carbohydrates can
be oxidized with sodium variety as we
looked at previously and silac acid or
beta deagle residues within these
structures can be oxidized with variety
to form two sides of aldehyde residues
one of the most interesting reactions is
the reaction between the amino acid
group and the aldehyde to form an oxime
this can be actually by Oh orthogonal if
care is taken during the reaction the
reaction is more efficient than
reactions between amines or hide resides
and carbonyls and axial bonds are
actually more stable than hydro-zone or
schiff base linkages the hydrolytic
stability of amines formed from ketones
is generally greater than those formed
with aldehydes except for aromatic
aldehydes like the cross linker I showed
in the previous slide which actually
forms a very stable oxime 's no
reduction is necessary in the bond to
stabilize the ax een axiom and if arrow
aldehydes or ketones are used cross
reactivity with normal functional groups
on biomolecules and avoided is avoided
due to a lower tendency to form shift
based interactions so an arrow aldehyde
like in the cross linker we just saw
will not form shift base cross links
with amines in solution but they will
react almost by orthogonal e with an
amine Lac C group to form an oxime
linkage
now there's one problem with this
reaction and that is with an aldehyde
and an amino actually group the
conjugation reaction occurs rather
slowly and some conjugation reactions
are slowed down because they're done at
very low concentrations typically and
this can significantly show slow down
the rate constants and oxime bond
formation in a paper published recently
in 2015 was found to be the slowest of
several common bio conjugation reactions
for instance it occurs considerably
slower than a Thyle maleimide coupling
reaction so if we look at the table the
aldehyde amino actually reaction to form
the axiom at pH 7 at 10 milli molar
concentration in room temperature the
rate constant was found to be point zero
zero one three fairly slow the copper
free click reaction by contrast done at
only 50 micromolar concentration at room
temperature had a much greater rate
constant of 0.9 and the copper catalyzed
click reaction done it
48 micro molar and room temperature at a
rate constant of three point four but I
mentioned previously that a thio
coupling to o'malley amide was very
efficient and this was done at only 15
micro molar at room temperature its rate
constant was 734 so you can see the
aldehyde amino actually reaction while
it forms a nice bond and it can be by OS
orthogonal in its native state just with
these two reactants present it's awful
slow so catalysts have been searched for
to accelerate this reaction years ago
Jenks and 64 identified aniline as a
catalyst to accelerate hydro-zone
formation and it works quite well for
oxime formation as well at ph 4.5
annalen was found to increase the
reaction rate of vaccine formation over
400 fold
on catalyzed reactions and since that
publication some other catalysts have
also been studied and most of them are
either aniline derivatives or diamino
benzene derivatives some of them enabled
the rate of the reaction to be hundreds
of times better than aniline alone and
how does this work so if we look at this
type of reaction you can think of an
amino x oxy modified molecule reacting
with an arrow aldehyde modified molecule
at the top and L aniline is put in
solution at 15 to 20 milli molar
concentration so it's much higher in
concentration than the typical
concentration of two proteins reacted
together so the first reaction that
occurs is the aniline nitrogen forms a
shift based linkage with the arrow
aldehyde group and the scene in the
middle intermediate aniline shift based
it just so happens that that aniline
shift base forms a better intermediate
for the amino group on the amino oxi
modified molecule to attack the carbonyl
in this linkage and form the final oxime
linkage so the rate of the reaction of
forming the oxime is actually catalyzed
by the aniline this works very well and
the other catalysts on the previous page
some of them even work at accelerated
rates than aniline does so in youth they
can be used to for instance modify a
particle with amino XE groups or aryl
aldehyde groups and then immobilize on
to the particle the corresponding
aldehyde or amino AXI containing ligand
and forming the terminal oxime bond in
the presence of annalen works very well
some interfering substances to look out
for for aldehyde or ketone conjugations
are listed here there's a lot of
biological molecules especially in cell
and tissue extracts can which contain
Elda hides or ketones aldehydes
containing compounds include reducing
sugars and derivatives glucose mannose
galactose ribose or e through throat
throws four phosphate Paradoxal
phosphate glyceraldehyde 3-phosphate of
acid aldehyde ketone containing
compounds include keto sugars and
derivatives like xylose acetone pyruvate
oxaloacetate dihydroxyacetone phosphate
progesterone testosterone cortisol
loveyou linic acid and five amino lovey
hellenic acid and the concentration of
aldehydes or ketones produced through
normal metabolic processes can vary from
low nano molar concentrations to high
micro molar concentrations so they can
compete very effectively with aldehyde
or ketone modified molecules that you
want to conjugate together other
molecules containing amines can also
interfere especially when conjugating
amines on proteins buffers containing
primary or secondary amines can
interfere when conjugating with amines
also a caveat is to not rinse glassware
with acetone if working with hydrazine
or amino oxy compounds because any
residual acetone will complex with ID
resides or amino oxys very effectively
and essentially inactivate it hydrozite
or amino oxy also watch out for
formaldehyde which is often released to
an oxidizing sugars with pariah date now
all these small molecules that may be
potentially interfering they can be
removed using dialysis or size-exclusion
chromatography prior to the final
conjugation reactions
so finally how do we create an optimal
Condry we've looked at a lot of the
functional groups we've looked at three
of the principle reactions that are done
on those functional groups but how to
create that optimal Condry and there's a
number of steps that I think are very
important to follow if you want to
optimize and produce possible country
and that is to design the conjugate with
the final application in mind as the
most important thing to start with the
best performance test in doing this is
the actual use of the conjugate in the
desired application also review the
literature for starting points on the
reagents reactions and conditions to use
knowing that all of those things will
have to be optimized further for your
application
use hydrophilic bio conjugation reagents
when possible
so there's many bio conjugate reagents
dozens and dozens that are available
ever have been made if you can find
those that have hydrophilic
characteristics and our water soluble
many of them contain discrete
polyethylene glycol spacers D peg
spacers also optimize the conjugation
method to achieve the highest possible
activity for the cons yet this means to
test different concentrations and mole
ratios different buffers and additives
different PHS for the reactions the
temperature being highly controlled
every potential parameter or factor
should be controlled for be careful not
to include substances that may interfere
with the reactions for example traceur
metal in amine reactions you can remove
most of the small molecule interfering
substances through size exclusion
chromatography or dialysis you scare to
prevent exposure to conditions that may
damage the conjugate source components
for example light sometimes damages
organics and some conjugation reagents
are highly sensitive to light oxidants
can damage redu
agents can damage others azide can
interfere use design of experiment
methods test multiple factors
simultaneously to achieve the best
possible manufacturing process finally
optimise the storage conditions to
ensure long-term stability and make
several batches using a final process to
ensure reproducibility if you take each
one of these steps in order and optimize
each step you'll end up at the end with
the best possible conjugate for your
application
now before I close I'd like to bring up
a couple of very important reagents that
I think are highly useful for developing
conjugates especially if you're
developing conjugates for important
applications like in Diagnostics of
therapeutics and that is Thermal has
come out with some premium-grade
reagents which are extra high purity
they have an enhanced level of testing
and characterization they're specially
designed for these type of applications
with lot retention policies change
management services and they have very
consistent manufacturing with batch
specific manufacturing documentation
that can be reviewed so I would
encourage you to if you're if you're
developing critical conjugates for
products do you think about using these
type of reagents from thermal and also
to make it very convenient to do
multiple development tests Thermal is
introduced noway reagents which reflect
the fact that you don't have to weigh
them out very convenient pre-weighed dry
reagents available in a single use PCR
strip or individual screw cap vial so
there's a milligram quantities of these
reagents within the vials and all you
have to do is add a buffer to dissolve
them or an organic solvent to dissolve
them and you're ready to go and this
helps save time by avoiding the need to
wake chemicals just add water buffer or
solvent helps reduce weights waste and
you don't have to go into a bulk bottle
repeatedly which can damage the
remaining compound within the bottle
also I'd like to point out before we
close for additional information I
encourage you to go to the latest
edition of my book bio conjugate
techniques has a long introduction
section to bio conjugation describing
many many applications it provides step
to step presentations of protocols which
makes the book of ideal source for
researchers who may not be familiar with
all the reactions and the protocols
it features full-color illustrations
molecular models and many many reactions
the new Edition also includes an
extensive introduction and one of the
most thorough overviews of
immobilization chemistry ever presented
and you can find this at my website at
Gregg Hermanson comm or at thermal
Fisher Scientific as well and finally
just to point out some of the
disclosures from thermal Fisher the
webinar has been provided by Greg
Hermanson incorporated sponsored by a
thermal Fisher Scientific but they don't
endorse anything I say I hope everything
has been very useful for your research
needs and your bio conjugation needs and
thank you again for attending
you
Thank You mr. Hermanson for that
informative presentation we will now
start the live Q&A portion of the
webinar if you have a question you'd
like to ask please do so now just click
on the ask a question drop-down box
located on the far left of your
presentation window type your question
into the box that appears on your screen
and click on the send button what
answers many of your questions as we
have time for now let's get started our
first question is seeing that a
maleimide reaction can give so many
different products do you recommend
using it that's a good question um it
certainly gives more products than the
traditional reaction scheme originally
presented in the literature and we've
come to know more about it over the last
10 years or so but even with those side
reaction products for most bio
conjugation reactions it works very well
extremely well it's very specific for
Thyle
conjugation and it reacts very very
rapidly so for standard reactions and
conjugates used in research and in
Diagnostics I would recommend highly
using it the only care I would say is
investigate thoroughly the potential for
different forms of the final product if
it if the final use of the conjugate is
to go into in vivo use of any kind
okay and you mentioned that TFP esters
give better yields than NHS esters or
soulful NHS esters do you recommend
switching to TFP esters to make
conjugate TFB esters are a great
alternative to nhf esters or cellphone
hf esters and if they are available I
would highly recommend testing both
types of esters on the same compound
side by side to see if in your
application the TFP ester will work the
best because it usually does result in
higher yields for the final yield of the
conjugate so yes I do recommend TFP
esters when they are available
you
I form an NHS ester or a sofa NH SS or
on a particle using EDC can I wash off
excess reactants before conjugation
without losing too much activity to
hydrolysis you know that actually is
typically done with particles the two
step EDC self-aligned HS or NHS
activation protocol forms the
intermediate activated ester and if
you're at a pH informing that ester
which is not too alkaline
I wouldn't recommend doing it anywhere
above pH 7.5 but you can quickly wash
off the excess of a DC and NHS or
cellphone HS from the particles before
adding the final molecule to conjugate
to them it works very well
excellent we have time for one more
question what is the best pH to use with
NHS ester reaction good question without
exactly definitive answer now I would
say the best range of pH is somewhere
between pH seven and nine but each
compound that you're using with an NHS
ester needs to be studied for the
optimal pH to use for instance a water
soluble compound where the NHS ester is
not next to any hydrophobic structures
usually hydrolyzes faster than an NHS
ester on a hydrophobic compound so if
you have a hydrophilic compound you're
probably going to find the optimal pH to
be somewhere in the low seven seven to
seven point five if you have a
hydrophobic compound with an NHS ester
on it the optimal pH may actually be
above 8.0 and with reactive fluorescent
dyes with NHS esters on them a lot of
times the optimal pH will be around pH
8.5 but with each new compound that
optimal pH conditions should be studied
but most often it's going to be
somewhere between pH seven and nine
all right thank you I would like to once
again thank mr. Hermanson for his
presentation I would also like to thank
Thermo Fisher Scientific for making
today's educational webcast possible now
before we go I want to let everyone know
that today's webcast will be available
for on-demand viewing through September
of 2019 please share with your
colleagues who may have missed today's
live event that's all for now thank you
for joining us and we hope to see you
again soon goodbye